hey guys Pete here today's the day I'm
starting my Twin Peaks rewatch starting
with the pilot episode of season 1 when
I asked the patrons on my patreon
account this was the overwhelming winner
of what they wanted to see was a rewash
of season 1 so I want to thank those
people for signing up and helping out to
make sure these videos happened and I
will give you a link at the end where
you can check out how to get involved
with that as well so I had to think
about this quite a bit because we've all
seen this we've all watched it several
times the only thing that's really
changed with it now is that season 3 has
come and gone we learned more about the
mythology and what's going on in both
season 3 and in the secret history of
Twin Peaks and to be honest this has
been done quite a few times over the
years this is a series that has never
really died except when it did die when
season 2 went off the rails and it's
just constantly been recycled in our
thought process for those of us who were
alive at that time this is my first time
rewatching it since season 3 aired
obviously I watched it beforehand to get
ready for season 3 and I have a
different take not a much bigger take
but I do have some things that I'll
point out towards the end here what
actually happens in this episode is we
learn about Laura's murder we're
introduced to the characters of the
small town of Twin Peaks in Washington
we see their reactions when the bodies
discovered we see FBI Special Agent Dale
Cooper arrive on the scene because
ronette Pulaski had crossed over state
lines we see that there is some
connection to another case that agent
Cooper had worked on we know that's
Theresa Banks that letter underneath the
fingernails is the key there and that
this might be a serial killer we learned
that there's more to Laura than what
everyone seems to know we know that she
had a boyfriend Bobby who had a secret
girlfriend Shelley and that Laura was
also seeing James on the side James
actually had a thing for Laura's friend
Audrey it turns out and those
you get together but there's something
that you have to notice right away Laura
never appears except for being wrapped
in plastic in the bag like a wonderful
bouquet but she is the main character
everything that happens in the beginning
of this series is related to people who
knew her their connections with her what
they thought about her whether they
liked her whether they didn't like her
so on and so forth she's very
complicated but at this point we don't
exactly know why we just know that
everybody has felt the pain of her death
there's two major things that came up
for me on this rewatch that I hadn't
thought about so much the last time I
watched it and the first one is that the
how just how straightforward everything
is as far as things go don't get me
wrong there's a very deliberate pace
that is slow for most people's tastes
and some people don't like the show
because of that but what really makes
this the compelling episode is the
straightforwardness of the tragedy of
the murder and the way that it affects
everyone what I've always remembered
about Twin Peaks after the fact is all
the crazy mysterious stuff that happens
you know with the lodges the strange
characters but there's really not any of
that in this Sara Palmer has a vision at
the end and that's really the only
supernatural event that I can think of
after watching this time the other thing
I noticed and I think this does have to
do with season three and watching that
is how efficiently each one of these
characters is defined and I think this
is a big mark frost influence here and
we meet them very quickly most of them
it's like I don't even know there has to
be 30 different people that we meet in
this hour and a half and we learn what
their deal is almost right away like we
just kind of they either say something
or they act away or they look away and
we get a really good idea of I want to
know more about this character because
of this you know it's pretty masterful
when you think about it I was reading
some things and you know somebody said
that the pilot of Twin Peaks is the best
piece of film that David Lynch ever made
and you know they of course attributed
that to the fact that he worked together
with Mark Frost here and the reason why
it's so bulletproof and stands up so
well is because that mutual
collaboration really paid off with it
comes to these two people coming
together and yeah this is you know
obviously this is that this is the
episode that they pitch this is the
story that they pitch they wrote this
one together David Lynch directed this
one and there's really no big problems
with it I think about it in retrospect
like does it hold up would young people
be able to watch this now and get into
it the same way I did at the time I
think the answer is probably no and I
think that pacing probably has something
to do with it but it doesn't make that
pacing better or worse than what we see
now it's just it was really good at what
it did you can see this throughout you
know TV shows from all eras and I think
that's what makes this timeless I mean
they look a little bit goofy because
it's the 90s and you know late 80s into
the 90s where things looked a little bit
goofy let me tell you I was there and at
the same time they're all kind of a
throwback I mean obviously Agent Dale
Cooper to throwback he's a character
that we don't see in TV anymore we trust
him he seems on the level he's happy
excited about life and we don't really
ever find anything out that contradicts
that that's way more of a you know
old-time kind of character good guy
nowadays everybody shades of gray I mean
he was pretty much a guy in a white hat
Harry has Truman's also the same we do
get a little bit of an idea that he's
sneaking around with Josie but that's
not all that terrible in any way the
people there aren't like trendy you know
what I mean this isn't Beverly Hills
90210 which is a contemporary show or
Miami Vice or something like that
they're they're kind of a throwback in a
small town anyways so I think it's kind
of timeless but I think what people
wouldn't like about it today is the same
thing that people started to stop liking
about it back then you know they liked
the idea of wanting to find out who
Laura Palmer's murderer was but they
didn't really care for all the expansive
plot lines that were going
everywhere that didn't necessarily have
a conclusion in mind you know what I
mean it's the same thing that we heard a
lot of when we saw the return finish up
people wanted answers they had waited
for answers they've been trained to
think that they deserve answers and when
they don't get them they decide to go
watch something else and that did happen
to this this this show didn't just die
because Lynch and frost stepped back
after they were forced to reveal the
killer there were other reasons involved
and we'll talk about that more as we go
for now it is it's fun watch for me I
enjoyed every moment of it it's a little
bit long but I can't think of anything
that could have been removed from it you
know what I mean it's a TV show yes it
should be somewhat consistent in a
timeframe but pilot episode is different
and I don't think that that really hurts
this here I think what's good about it
now is what was good about it for me the
things that stand out the Leland and
Sarah's reaction that whole sequence I
think is really powerful I think that
when we see Harry he never says your
daughter's dead Leland just knows the
phone drops both were really good
performances and it really tied in there
the students reactions I'm not a big fan
of the students I have to be honest
about that I don't really like those
storylines that much I understand why
they're there but I you know when I
watched it even back then I was I was
never into that those parts of the story
I mean Audrey was interesting but the
James and Donna stuff it just kind of
always graded me for some reason
Cooper obviously he steals the show but
we talked about that a bit already and
for all the quirkiness and Zane eNOS you
know things are pretty quickly moved
along like we meet the log lady for
instance one of my favorite characters
and Cooper says what who's the lady was
the log and Truman just says we call her
the log lady and there's nothing else to
it you know we don't get a big thing and
I think that's what makes the pilot kind
of stand out compared to everything else
that we see in the Twin Peaks universe
is that they kept things moving along to
build up the idea that this girl's death
had a major
on people and it made me want to know
who killed her and I think it probably
did you too if you're watching this
video at this point because 25 plus
years later we're still talking about
this show a couple of interesting things
of note here I mentioned the log lady
earlier when they came back and put this
out in syndication on the Bravo network
they had the log lady do introductions
for the episodes each individual episode
these are interesting because they were
made up after the series had been
cancelled and they went back and they
put little introductions for each one
and the intro she uses here is welcome
to Twin Peaks my name is Margaret
Lanterman I live in Twin Peaks I'm known
as the log lady there's a story behind
that there are many stories in Twin
Peaks some of them are sad some funny
some of them are stories of madness of
violence some are ordinary yet they all
have about them a sense of mystery the
mystery of life sometimes the mystery of
death the mystery of the woods the woods
surrounding Twin Peaks to introduce this
story let me just say it encompasses the
all it is beyond the fire the few would
know that meaning it's a story of many
but it begins with one and I knew her
the one leading to the many is Laura
Palmer Laura is the one so of course she
repeated that idea in season three and
it's a really straightforward coherent
kind of idea right those are the things
I was talking about earlier everything
revolves around Laura originally that
was the plan and the idea was that the
mystery of who killed Laura Palmer
wasn't going to be the foreground story
at first but it was going to disappear
into the background gradually as viewers
started to get invested in the other
storylines of the regular people in the
town
initially the networked liked that idea
but over time they gave in to the fans
wishes of wanting to know who actually
committed the murder
a couple of interesting things that
and around the set was that if you
remember that scene where they're
looking at binds the letter under
Laura's fingernail the light is
malfunctioning I guess you could say is
sort of flickering and that was
something that happened when they were
filming and David Lynch just liked it
and decided not to have it fixed another
thing that's a pretty famous story that
you've probably heard is that Bob the
guy who plays Bob Frank Silva he was
discovered during filming he you know he
wasn't initially cast as anything he was
a stagehand or whatever you would call
that and Lynch heard somebody say
something about Frank getting caught in
a room where they were rearranging
furniture being stuck there David Lynch
liked the idea of that so he ended up
making him Bob and that had an effect on
the writing of the future episodes as
far as I know there's also the story
about Laura she was cast to play the
person in the plastic the dead body she
shot the obviously shot the photos for
the iconic images that we see throughout
the series the one that's most
noticeable of course is her homecoming
queen photograph but when they filmed
the video that we see in this episode
with her and Donna David Lynch I guess
liked it so much that that's how she
ended up being cast again as Maddie and
so on so there's some interesting things
to think about another thing I was
thinking about going into this was how
does it hold up as far as B you know its
own height basically people still give
this show a lot of credit for changing
TV into what we see now and I think
that's obviously true question I had in
my mind when I was watching is how does
this hold up compared to the third
season and to all the shows that have
came afterwards I mean even if you don't
think that Twin Peaks changed TV I mean
I guess if you think that you probably
weren't there whenever this happened but
even if you don't think that you have to
understand that it did expand the
toolbox of what was possible with TV
especially net this was network TV this
was like primetime on a major network
and when we get into some of the
episodes especially the being season 2
it's pretty amazing
to think about the fact that they showed
it at that time so if nothing else that
expanded the toolbox so every show that
came after it had this in their toolbox
so how does it hold up in that instance
I think it still is compelling I think a
lot of the shows that kind of wanted to
jump on to what Twin Peaks achieved in
the beginning you know they kind of
focused on the weird and here we see
that it's able to jump back and forth in
between different kinds of genres very
quickly it's equally good at being funny
as it is about being up like a police
procedural TV show we see it do that and
it's really a credit to the writing
because I don't think you see that that
often there's plenty of shows out there
who do one thing really well and there's
funniest shows that have come after Twin
Peaks that are much better as far as
being consistent through the run of the
series but in the landscape it came out
in and doing the things that it did it
still holds up and it's not that dated
when you compare it to other TV shows
and how they might hold up I mean think
about Breaking Bad how is that gonna
look in 20 years you know what I mean
there'll be shows that he'll take things
that are good from it and do them really
well and you know Jesse Pinkman won't
really look right in the context of the
time it's being watched and all that
kind of stuff so I'm excited to continue
on with this series I'm excited to hear
what you guys think ask me questions for
sure as I mentioned at the beginning
this is directly related to the people
who have helped me out on patreon who
are my supporters over there
this is what they wanted to see and this
is what they have signed up for and I
would like to give you guys a link to go
there and think about joining as well
everything you know it need to know is
explained there so I'm not going to
pitch you about it here just check it
out and see what you think please like
this video if you enjoyed it definitely
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already leave your thoughts in the
comments follow me on my social media
accounts you can leave some comments and
we can discuss it over there as well
just to give you an idea of how I got
into Twin Peaks I was introduced to
David Lynch through blue velvet I first
watched that in my height
years back then they used to have
mom-and-pop video stores and
neighborhoods in cities it was before
blockbuster sort of took over that whole
thing and they would have a pretty good
variety believe it or not even in small
towns and blue velvet was on the shelves
one day it stood out as something
interesting because it had the little
palm leaves on it as it had won some
awards and me and my friend picked it up
we watched it and we didn't really know
what we thought about it but we loved it
so that kind of opened the door to a lot
of things to me and I I mostly watch
David Lynch's movies as they appeared so
most of them in the theaters over the
years but I'm not been a huge David
Lynch obsessed kind of fan I've always
enjoyed his work I think he's great I
think that he approaches moviemaking as
an artist approaches making visual art
or a musician making music and I think
it's really refreshing most of the time
the thing about Twin Peaks was I didn't
watch TV when it came out at all like
I'd you know nobody really did I was a
teenager it came out in 1990 so I was in
my senior year of high school so I was
about the age of the people that were in
the show there was a lot of hype about
it I did know David Lynch I knew this
was an interesting thing and what really
got me into it was an older kid I knew
was talking about it and you know I'm
not really sure if he hadn't if I really
would have watched it when it first came
out really enjoyed fire walk with me
when it first came out I was more into
movies and TV shows think pretty much
everybody was the quality of movies was
a lot higher than TV was at that time
core Twin Peaks paid a big part in that
changing over the last couple decades
but yeah look when Peaks open the door
to re watching and re watching over the
years
definitely watch season one more than
season two but both of them are good
although season two definitely has its
problems but we're gonna do season one
here one see how it goes and then if it
does if it you know probably if the
patreon still going and there's still
interest then we will go straight
through season two as well I do have to
mention the music in season one after
watching season three which I loved and
I mean obviously you can
compared both because seasons 1 & 2 were
made at a different time when nothing
like that at all was on TV so of course
season 3 would be different but I
probably like season 3 the best out of
all of them but the music in season 1 &
2 is just amazingly cool it's like an
extra character in the scenes I think
sometimes and even though we got it in
smaller doses in season 3 I really enjoy
the saturation of the music in season 1
and season 2 so in the next installment
which will be following sometime next
week I guess we'll get to see an episode
that Lynch and Frost wrote but David
Lynch did not direct there's a different
director so we'll see how that holds up
until then thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon